There's been some fascinating research
to suggest that when we play games and
we tap into positive emotions like
curiosity and optimism and creativity,
and,
and even love that these emotions
actually stayed with us for up to 24
hours after we finished playing the
game.
So studies have shown that we're more
likely to cooperate with someone in our
real lives after we played a social game
with them,
where we're doing some kind of
cooperative mission over more likely to
set an ambitious goal for ourselves.
After we've succeeded in a game,
we'll,
we'll speak up more for ourselves.
We'll even flirt with more attractive
strangers.
So there's this kind of transfer of our
confidence,
of our creativity,
of our,
of our ambition to our real lives.
We have this idea that playing games is
kind of a waste of time,
um,
that it's not a very productive way to
spend our time.
And I kept hearing that even as I was
evangelizing all of the benefits of
gaming,
the emotional benefits of social,
the psychological benefits people kept
saying,
yeah,
but it's,
it's just a waste of time.
Shouldn't we be doing something more
productive than,
you know,
avenging some angry birds.
And it really made me wonder,
well,
what do we mean by productive?
I mean,
productivity is about producing
something.
What do we really want to produce more
of in our lives and in the lives of the
people around us?
You know,
are we trying to produce more emails or,
you know,
are we trying to produce more positive
emotion?
Are we trying to produce stronger
relationships?
Are we trying to produce a sense of
meaning and purpose?
And it turns out that Games are actually
quite good at producing those things.
That's what they produce more of and
better than almost anything else.
So when people say Games are a waste of
time and not productive,
I would challenge them to ask
themselves,
what do you want to produce more of?
And if it's things like better
relationships and more positive emotion
in my daily life than games might be the
most productive thing you can do.